all right we've been talking about
national dog day all morning krispy
kreme selling doggy
donuts
they look more like cookies they're like
little bitty cookies well so we didn't
want to make nate eat one of them i
appreciate that thank you i appreciate
it
producer viv
this is leo hi leo hi so viv has stepped
up from behind the scenes hey viv it's
good to see you out here on tv
and this is leo how old is leo he's for
leo's four he was a he was rescued in
montana yes okay yeah does he like
treats uh he typically does it's a
little hit or miss okay i'm gonna see
how this goes okay let's see let's give
him one well he's been very interesting
oh no problem oh oops
this is the lick and sniff test should
we try another flavor oh yeah what else
you got in the box what if i put it down
here on the floor leo you want to pick
one anything look good to you there
buddy you want a treat
try this
okay he's very particular apparently you
want to know what's in these whole wheat
flour peanut butter sugar vegetable fat
and carob instead of chocolate because
you know dogs have chocolate so they're
healthy for dogs yeah i think leo wants
liver chicken and you know other you
want something a little more beefy they
look so cute though sprinkles on there
and everything leo what do you think
well now we're getting doggy grouper
overall dog tested so nate do you want
to do you want to try one now well
they'll go doggy goober on them
this one does and i salvaged that one do
you want to try it it it really doesn't
look so good with you yeah i can't eat
like a rock
[Laughter]
don't try this at home kids leo's
looking at you like what are you eating
hey looks pretty good man i just tried
it yeah that was good yeah pretty good
oh
he said that's good
if it's good enough for nate it's good
enough for leo
did high fives man i'd high five yet
i think you've convinced him i think so
too nate that's all we needed was just a
little incentive all right i think
leo must like the taste of cardboard
well napoleon does because
that's yeah my dog loves cardboard shoes
cardboard all the time there's my doggy
nala oh yeah chilling on the back patio
we've got everybody's dogs gone this
morning how cute crystal gus and nala
and our director andra says meelo there
tart and ryan's coming up have a great
weekend